flier storiche e allora allora ciao
scusa allora spero che devo scrivere mi
dispiace ragazzi scusatemi oggi ho fatto
una cosa un po strana ho fatto live
prima mi dispiace un sacco scusatemi
solo che stasera dovevo registrare delle
cose e dobbiamo registrare le robe st
server cose che usciranno che vedrete
quindi mi scuso oggi ho dovuto
anticipare e ve l'ho detto con basso
anticipo scusate il gioco di parole
perché solo stamattina ho capito che
stasera non potevo registrare perché
finivo troppo tardi finisco dopo le 9
forse anche le 10 quindi non potevo più
più farla la live stasera a loro detta
bella anticipo
perdonatemi perdonatemi anche quelli che
si vedranno la live che rimane salvata
dopo perché ho dovuto registrare la
prima per forza di cose o non la facevo
proprio ora facevo adesso quindi o
saltava la live la faceva ad essere tab
e facciamo adesso mi dispiace che
usatemi scusatevi davvero colpa mia
colpa mia è purtroppo non potevo fare
diversamente dobbiamo recare delle robe
importanti stiamo preparando il video
dei 5 milioni di iscritti e per far
cavalca i capelli e per prepararlo serve
un sacco di tempo e il tempo e tutti i
giorni da due settimane dovrà recare
tutti i giorni delle cose stasera
compresa quindi stasera
scusatemi scusami davvero e non capita
mai in teoria di spostarla live laddove
dovesse capitare per cause proprio di
forza strana maggiore va bene va bene
quindi oggi oggi oggi va così oggi va
così giovedì tranquillamente la sua no
sì giovedì la sera come sempre quindi a
posto per oggi con gli strati che lo
scrivo sotto in descrizione di tutti
quelli che si connettono chiama perché
c'è la live adesso almeno leggono perché
lo scrivo qua importante tante due punti
la live di oggi è stata anticipata
anticipata al dalle 15 e 45 fino alle 18
e che facciamo tre in 13 e 30 anche se
non è vero da pazienza fino alle 18
perché stasera devo registrare delle
cose ed non e non avrei potuto fare la
fila
perdonatemi vi voglio bene uguale no
questo no perché sono tanto polacca puro
perdonatemi
la live rimarrà comunque sull sul canale
bene oggi finisce oggi finisce finiamo
ali di slash dei sum sta bene tutto a
posto
non posso tirarlo fuori tre secondi per
questo canale non è un canile ma è un
canale quindi non è che devo basarmi
conto di solo sul cane per ora
ciao sofia ciao sniper dato adesso non
equa perché sta la verità che siccome il
cucciolo noi dobbiamo fare i controlli
di vaccini
quindi se c'era la mia mamma che lo
porta a vedere se è tutto a posto quindi
il vaccino
insomma un po di cazzi che ci sono
quando c'è un cane all'inizio perché è
normale e con questa bene si diverte
mangia gratta tutto gratta anche
qualsiasi cosa mi ha grattato anche i
gioielli allora andiamo avanti fino
all'election scusatemi per chi si è
connesso adesso la live inizia a leggere
in descrizione perché la il velo
anticipata oggi sorry sorry mi dispiace
però dovevo fare per forza così o
saltava la live dovrebbe esserci tutto
lessico oggi finiamo oggi finiamo alien
se dio vuole ok d'opal in giochi a
rocket
non lo so non lo so perché chi è che è
successo ciao arthur favino potresti
fare video su del tar un da almeno 30
minuti perché facendo video da solo 13
minuti e lo so però in 30 minuti faccio
due episodi non è lunghissimo per quel
motivo l'isola 30 minuti montati è
veramente peso forse colando under the
hill potrò fare trenta minuti forse con
under the il faro 30 minuti il problema
è che del tar un allora di tu devi
pensare anche al grande pubblico perché
nel mio canale devi per forza pensare
anche a quello e quindi lani la nicchia
di pubblico vuole che non tace vorrebbe
che in italia si mai il pubblico normale
di youtube però esige purtroppo delle
direttive diverse da quelle che
preferireste voi quindi devi dargli del
ritmo perché sono la gente si addormenta
c'è la gente quando vedevo da un video
youtube sembra che si deve fare una rai
a di cocaina quindi devi tenerli il
ritmo e quindi non posso fare cioè
potrei fare trenta minuti montati solo
che ci sarebbero tre video in uno è dove
lo trovo il tempo è veramente difficile
fare però forse con under the hill farò
così
trenta minuti in o magari 20 non lo so
adesso vediamo
sicuramente comunque questo episodio di
delta non era molto più corto degli
altri gli altri saranno un po più lunghi
non 30 minuti
altra cosa iniziato del tar un è però io
sapevo che comunque nei commenti tutti
ma è vero ski dei giocata ad under the
hill prima lo so
ed è proprio per questo che ho dovuto
giocare prima del tar 1 e perché è bello
secondo me vedere una persona che non ho
mai giocato ad under the hill come si
affaccia ad un mondo del cie bello che
io chiamo la mucca che parla il
personaggio di che voi già conoscete in
under the leveaux e dite no ma quello
non è una mucca che parla quella è
non mi ricordo quindi è proprio bello
secondo me per questo motivo perché voi
sapete conoscete i personaggi io no
quindi voi dite cavolo lui è quello è
lui non lo sa neanche capito
e poi perché del tar non è nuovo di
nuovo quindi sempre a livello di
pubblico fa di più e poi se piace
porterò porterò in chianti fi match all
leonardo
snai perciò sofia lesmo partiamo con all
isola ora dobbiamo finirlo lo finiamo lo
finiamo che invece se non riesci a
finirlo oggi non ho probabilmente lo
finirò oggi perché siamo sul finale
quindi anzi non riuscirò per due ore e
mezzo a fare solo alien perché siamo
proprio sul finale del siamo sul finale
del gioco quindi non lo so allora ce lo
godiamo questo finale ragazzi impronti
amoci e facciamo le cose giuste da
allora munizioni volt che hanno
innanzitutto e carichiamo sta bella
bellezza si vede si sente vanno anche le
cose latera laterali quindi sono
commosso molto bene va bene ero rimasti
che dobbiamo dare al centro medico
perché la bomba non ha ucciso tutti gli
alien va beh ovviamente tutta la gente
che ai bot non l'ho ancora aggiustato
vabbè
lasciate perdere il bot
anzi aspettate un attimo spero un
secondo perché thomas che vi gestisce il
bot
è una cosa molto brutta da dire ma è
vero io non sono capace non me ne
intendo quindi io devo dire
tom scusami se ti rompo le scarpe da
otto team hanno visto chiaramente sto
facendo la live appena il tempo proprio
riesci a mettermi source and taste asse
starmi il boat della live per chi non so
proprio come fare cioè non mi ricordo
chi come avevamo fatto quindi dovresti
farlo perché non ho io mi dici come si
fa perché non
non sono lì e non rimane che continua a
dire che alla che sono la domenica
esclusa la rottura
ecco così assistiamo bot
no perché mi scusatemi ma non so come
abbasso il volume di chi mio del live
mio pro la propria prova però forse il
prova quale volume alto il mio quello
del prova brava brava la quale volume
alto però la brava brava brava brava
prova comunque lei è una capra non è una
mucca cece scusami cioè adesso non mi
ricordano anche di chi stai parlando era
un esempio come di corna che va bene e
[Risate]
grazie alla bora che se pasquale grazie
non leggo i nomi ragazzi perché sono
sentiti thank you partiamo a il mio
microfono era alto va bene adesso
dovrebbe essere a posto no ho abbassato
un po va bene si è quindi andiamo al
centro medico che di qua che ovviamente
chiuso che ovviamente aperto o fly mi
chiamano no niente non ho nessun colpo
di nulla
hilton fa non ci va la hilton fa non è
che sia utile revolver non c'è non c'è
niente ci avevo tutti i proiettili a
[ __ ] ottimo
devo andare verso il centro medico
lorenz il centro medico sta dove e non
mi dico se non mi dite dove c'è dove c'è
il centro medico
quale delle due devo prendere questa non
mi dici quale devo prendere per andare
all incrocio medico e volevo dirvi
arakan ei commenti se qualcuno chiede le
cane rispondete league anche nonché dal
veterinario perché se non posso
rispondere
ogni 4 secondi alla gente che non mi ha
sentito che lo ho detto datemi la mano
da bravi vi prego ancora come ancora
alto ma siete sordi prova prova minchia
più al più basso di così non vi sentite
più adesso va bene microfono mi chiamo
veramente abbassa ancora un po
sentimentale scemi come se sicuri prova
proprio adesso va bene io lo vedo già
allora strano giallo vuol dire che ha
posto 6 sicuri abbassato ancora uno che
più di così non vi sentite più
avere amica dove siete ok di ritorno
europeo giusto così
e la navetta sbagliata e la navetta
sbagliata la navetta giusta ha lottato
micron anche quello chiamato questo
proviamo a vedere se non hanno
va bene comunque ragazzi se lo finisco
prima delle due ore e mezzo dai dovrebbe
finire per le due ore per le 18 e un
quarto
se stiamo proprio perché due ore e mezza
l'ho iniziata alle 3 45 quindi definita
18 un quarto
come si dice dopo se finisce
se finisce dall'acese finisco il gioco
prima della live
facciamo un po di più e nei quelli nella
chat che mi aiutano a rispondere a
quelli che non sanno che same dal
veterinario vi dovete fare un come si
dice
il segno della croce perché la gente
continuerà a chiederlo per tutto il
video l'annuncio già gli ormai conosco
il mondo di youtube grazie pasquale
grazie moby grazie a le grazie barbara
[Musica]
same dal veterinario ragazzi purtroppo
purtroppo cioè non è che sta male se
devi fare i controlli dei cuccioli
no no no no no
ma con me
porca vacca ma è anche qua
buono a sapersi veloce cava che non
pensava bene mi sono già mandato a
[ __ ] metà colpi ottimo se ti apri
velocemente mi fai un piacere grazie
meno male che ha avuto la prontezza di
tirar fuori lancia più veloce grazie
molto bene
ora che c'è fate così scrivete nella
chat same dal veterinario fate copia col
tasto destro coppia veste sete al
telefono copiate con il telefono la
frase è ogni volta che lo chiede
incollati alla frase perché sono due
tedeschi con mille con ormai la gente
pensa solo al cane
perché non avete mi chiamo bene 30
rinnovata una nave in avvicinamento
dobbiamo sta attaccando interrotto il
discorso va bene
when where is it dall'altra parte
perfetto perfetto ho sbagliato
raga non è che dovete incollarlo di
continuo la frase solo quando me lo
chiede dichiara mai fino a tutta la live
st frau slam e la vetrina l'esame davide
dovete incollarono quando qualcuno lo
chiede rega cava sari qua no
dunque mi fa piacere che alien sia
esattamente qui va verso
comunque tra sun e alien non so chi chi
morda di più perfetto che c'è un cestino
che è saltato da solo fantastico cioè
andiamo
corre tanto chi se ne frega molto bene
molto bene secondo me tra neanche un'ora
abbiamo finito ciao isaia grazie della
donazione
grazie mille io non sento le donazioni
però devo aumentare il volume di qua
perché non le sto sentendo ciao isaia
grazie grazie mille ciao a te potete
spostarla meglio che arrivi qualcosa
ciao grazie e millesimo grazie millesimo
se il super gentile isaia anche un bel
nome
sì lo vedo
ho sbagliato strada non andare
di caricatura essendo che dopodomani a
comprarli mio cugino per salutarlo pensa
rimessa integrato si chiama nicolò
perdona la richiesta non ti preoccupare
tanto non ricevuto milioni al giorno di
queste richieste di salou dvd tranquillo
ciao nicolò buon compleanno buono
compleanno nicolò ricevo io ormai potrei
far aprire un canale di salute tanto mi
chiedono soldi per qualsiasi cosa
dove dico tutti i nomi così ogni volta
che dovete salutare gli amici o
prendetela lì c'è una cosa devo dargli
fuoco posso andare via anche senza se
magari esco dal menu che veloce veloce
veloce lascia fare
non ci credo vicolo cieco a me la
ricordo st parte purtroppo mari gol anzi
fammi salvare già che ci sono
questo lo devo tutto no però non è più
specie esplodeva una volta ci ricordate
quante volte l'ho fatto sta parte
ecco
ho sentito dei passi orribili però vabbè
corro corro chissenefrega trucchia ciao
non corriamo non corriamo adesso
dobbiamo andare a salvare quindi mi
serviva fare questa cosa mi servirebbero
dei colpi di lanciafiamme se dio vuole
però mi sa che è difficile lo zio è
uscito da qualche parte devo andare di
qua
porca vacca
ciao leo ciao mano un grazie mille 100
passi bruttissimi non capisco dove però
lancia lanciafiamme in mano scusatemi
ecco dai c max sfiga o era arrivato
porca vacca
ma no non mi ha visto ancora regalo dai
veloce veloce ci siamo arrivati
se continuo a muovermi così siamo
arrivati però di andare veloce che ho h
quanto bollente molto bene
i gay sono ambulanze trovare uno shuttle
va bene dowling figura
ciao leo grazie mille
ti stimo tantissimo grazie cerca un
potenziamento scusami eh no no no vabbè
in groppa t he lived devo trovare un
potenziamento quando lo trovo scusa
cerca un potenziamento per livello 3 per
il sintetizzo tecnico ma è come lo trovo
ma qui
qui devo trovare un potenziamento some
sta bene è tutto a posto
capisce non sento il lanciafiamme non lo
tengo in mano si protetto questo mi min
gruppo uguale dove dovevo è d'oro
potenzia scusa
devo potenziali sintetizzatore ma
scusami qua in questa stanza
qua
no come lo trovo potenzialmente
sintetizzato da uno studio nel caso ma
siamo sicuri che devo stare qua mi date
un micron una micro dritta perché mi fa
strano che io che qua ci sia un
potenziamento per l'inter c'è più niente
la faccio girata la volta poi basta
potenziamento sintetizzatore
ecco lo hai visto ai potenziato
sintetizzo parto ciao giulia ciao mattia
caprile antonin gabriele grazie mille
per la donazione ragazza si e solo forza
fiammate
se riesco a creare sta roba lo faccio
bene sono proprio bravissimo c'era un
potenziamento per il sintetizzatore poco
nella stanza in cui mi serviva
va bene abbiamo shuttle tanto al mille
per mille mi si attacca un alien alla
navicella già lo sento stiamo per
scappare
quindi credo tanto so già che c'è un
fila benissimo siamo partiti fuori dalle
balle molto bene
dove stiamo andando ragazzi a busto
arsizio
cos'è dove stiamo fine
siamo sulla necid ora l'altra nave il
problema è che anche qui son sicuro che
non è che siamo tranquilli questa è
l'altra nave quella di partenza immagini
tra qui questa è la necid ora bellanesi
d'ora come non è per la nave
ma no
esplora la necid ora va bene esplorando
la navicella quante cose che impariamo
spc grazie alla donazione
thank you so much dei sistemi riavvio
quando cosa tipo quando riavvii computer
li avvia al sistema ok re start computer
o un casino ma cosa mi dai
così del lanciafiamme fantastico ti
voglio bene
cambio da immagino che sara varti la
porta 4 5 10 e nel codice anche se non
ho capito quando serve 45 10 questo 45
10 poi mi fa ridere che ci sono sempre i
codici che ti dicono il compiuta il
computer di fianco cioè la sistemi di
sicurezza dista nave sono inutili
in tutto il gioco e così questa cosa non
l'ho mai capita cioè spiegami perchè c'è
scritto ovunque in codice per aprì la
porta ma la mia basso rio tubicino
scritta sulla porta del dell'altro
studio boh
pietro che fine ha fatto ho un po
scomparso un po che per tutti quanti
questi giorni magari lo sento
ultimamente ho sentiamo proprio poco
pietro sta partendo
ho avviato però non funziona bene o
almeno io li lavano non ce la metto poi
non so voi
facciamo che stiamo qua
queste per riavviare i sistemi
siamo sicuri non schiacciare delle cose
qua devo schierare il sistema ackermann
va bene for my soul sintetizzatore
d'accesso
ecco ecco no secco no
dietro in live ora andate lì a dire che
tutta
anzi scrivete licia e amiche con lei
alla fine vi prego in massa descrivere
vi prego
ho riavviato secondo me non funziona
benissimo
comincia dei problemi sta nave però non
fa niente
lo schiacciate le 9 quando vado fuori ha
avviato è riccardo mi sento base della
misura i portelli dovrebbero aprirsi e
speriamo torni veloce ancora porca vacca
si parlò dove 6 marzo
quando gioco a forma di t e adesso il
gioco forme finisco qua il gioco ha
fornito finisco il video grazie comunque
per donazione del gioco a forte netta
per finisco di qua cinque minuti le
giochiamo a fort mente trova amarlo ok
ecco la portata lane signora nello
spazio di sevastopol a nello spazio di
non capivo la francia lo troviamo c'è
veramente siamo vicini a sebastopol che
la nave di prima dove c'è alain perfetto
era esattamente quello che non doveva
succedere io e non sarebbe male ma come
ok c'erano insetti pazienti qualcosa non
mi dice che qualcosa mi dice che se
tizio non è a posto però vabbè messaggio
ok all audio
vabbè ma gesù perché un qualsiasi nave
in cui vado muoio c'è gente ciao france
ciao zio ti adoro anche io ti adoro tra
scavalcano io ho pagato aspetta e niente
ciao bene vedo vi siete molto prolifico
le domande grazie a un'ottima fase
grazie mille per il supporto davvero
gruppo profit e non lo dico io trovano
grazie mille france è se non fossi se
hai portato a sull'asse vasto un po di
problemi al cervello lo hai visto che
c'è quello schifo di però vabbè non fa
niente non puoi c'è impossibile quella
zecca si attacca qualsiasi cosa non puoi
alieni non si può sconfiggere ce ne sono
un miliardo quanto anche se pensi averlo
sconfitto comunque ci saranno all in in
giro quindi non puoi farlo fuori mai ce
ne sono troppi
mi sono morire cerca di sopravvivere il
più possibile comunque non era finito
subito ancora un po ce n'era ricorda
l'ex signor marlowe quello che non sa
pilotare le le astronavi usa il
terminale va bene
beh ma io a fi come normale per questo
devo fare io non problema insomma un co
accedere a facebook questa tastiera è
stranissimo
io e mia madre
questo messaggio per te ti sarò mio
spero che riceverai questo messaggio un
giorno nei guai siena c'è stato un
incidente
abbiamo trovato una creatura aliena era
molto pericolosa
l'unico modo per fermarla era
distruggere la nave
sto bene sono in una scialuppa molto
lontana
[Musica]
dovevamo distruggere dovevamo
distruggere il nostromo non potevamo
rischiare di portare quella perché con
noi dovete proteggervi
non preoccuparti non preoccuparti per me
ci vediamo molto presto ti voglio bene
bambina mia ma quindi non ho capito è
morta o no perché qua mi dice che si è
salvata cioè se sei sulla scialuppa però
non dice che è morta morta è morta
perché non l'ho mai più vista quindi è
morta per forza però non è che lo dice
peggiora peso peso scriveva col martello
in mano e vero è perché l'ho ripassato
prima eccoli no
no no no no d'azzardo zio fa cagate e
vabbè
non posso vantarmi ma eccola consentirò
alla compagnia per poi congelato da casa
sua
sì però moriamo tutti moriamo moriamo
tutti non si sia accorto che moriamo lì
c'è praticamente lui e per quello che
questo era avvicinato e come far saltare
tutto che l'altro non avea e per quello
che si è avvicinato prima brava mi
chiama ci avrei mai pensato a parte che
se ti hanno sparato
cioè no in realtà è la ferita di prima
io faccio da quattro pedala porca vacca
se esista sovraccaricando louks non
sarebbe metà musica salta in aria la
nave però ei martin garics
si sta sovraccaricando un sacco se non
far accogliere qua
beh magari lo facciamo dopo dove che
devo andare a quale devo fare
porco demonio sta saltando tutto aspetta
eccolo qua mi sa che non ce la facciamo
a me non sta saltando tutto in aria un
problema
ora non lo terminale
vedo gesù li in mezzo
minchia sta saltando in aria regalo di
far veloce
ok lo forzare l'accesso io stavo con le
mani in mano
in piazza tutti lo vendo tutto non c'è
per noi non ce la faremo mai
non ce la faremo mai ecco io l'ho detto
io ci ho provato
doveva andare così a non doveva andare
così come non devo andare così
mi chiedo fatto quello doveva forse ho
aspettato troppo
che palle va bene
la cielo vi facciamo lo più veloci ci ho
messo una vita mikado devo togliere
tutto io devo fare non preso per un
elettricista meccanico tutto la mia arma
è rimasta quando sono morto ottimo
dai dai veloci veloci veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce
c'era la mi è rimasta lì l'arma ciao
giulia
allora e per due live non ho donato
perché mi hanno votato la carta freddo
ma guarda che non ce n'è bisogno giulia
grati ringrazio ma c'è le live le faccio
lo stesso anche senza la nazione quindi
non ti preoccupare non non suonare che
l'orco demonio porco demonio che devo fà
ma devo fare un'altra cosa ma va a
cagare ma è un ora che sto qua mi che
penso che la spec non schiacciare dopo
quello forse le oche pirla io penso di
aver finito ma dove usare l'altra cosa
scusate per per dare sto dicendo non c'è
bisogno delle donazioni per le live
io le faccio uguale c'è nel senso se mi
volete supportare son contento però non
stare a fare donazioni ogni tot e
tranquilla grazie va a prezzo tra i
tantissimo ma tranquilla ti preoccupare
proprio
se facessi solo live ok ma non faccio
solaio quindi tranquilli non ce n'è
proprio bisogno ti ringrazio molto se
molto gentile però tranquillissima
davvero non deve fare più c'è fatte
tante ma purtroppo basta
grazie mille grazie traian case
francesco cioè devo fare questa cosa non
avevo capito sono scemo
non avevo capito e non solo non mi
intendo di ingegneria aerospaziale
scusatemi
eh sì
può essere che salta uguale
va beh
cosa facciamo io guardo la mia arma che
è rimasta
e vabbè scappa punto esclamativo
vabbè aiuto e vabbè vabbè succedono le
cose ragazzi mi sa che come meccanico
non sono tanto gettonato è non chiamate
mese vi si scassa la macchina che lo
scasso di più vorrei uscire ci riusciamo
usciamo da ovunque
niente sono marco demonio aiuto e di
rimettersi la tuta e uscire fortissimo
sono vivo dove che vado dove vado di qua
è l'unica porta ok mi dice rivolta porca
vacca la grande volta fa c'era almeno
tutte le cose almeno tutti gli alien sim
o muoiono almeno quello
scappa scappa scappa dal club degli dei
si scappa si scappa mica rega sono nella
cassetta e niente
abbiamo scelto l'hotel o gesù è stato
proprio difficile nel caso di quante ne
fosse accorto stai per morire esatto
scappa punto esclamativo
e beh cosa volevo fare guardare il fuoco
e chissenefrega mai contattato
mi chiedevo fare tutto io trova il modo
di contattare la torres ma perché sono
io faccio qualcosa perché sto facendo
tutto io poi fate qualcosa
scappa c'è il nemesis
si no cerchi del nemesis e sono tanti di
noi e dove che vado trovari caro anche
lascia aperto il canale non fare idea
grazie sano grazie al 100 grazie traian
[Musica]
benvenuti un cazzo però va bene come si
arriva esattamente in qualche modo di
misura alla sicurezza della simpson
beh sì perché io non ho l'onore e già
visto sono comunque legati ragano no non
ho proiettili no no non posso non ho
proiettili capito non posso difendermi
c'è solo un colpo di fucile a pompa
la vodka mi va di usare la volta della
gente c'è la sicurezza della simpson c'è
non so se vi rendete conto
ho bisogno di colpire che devo farlo
fuori sennò non prendo colpi ma prendi i
colpi prendi i colpi aia affanculo
e vabbè pro di morire
porca vacca un colpo tirato neanche
quello neanche quello
cristo un colpo di ratti che palle
era che non ho colpe come la faccia star
non o colpi di niente con la lancia
fiaba che usiamo lanciafiamme però poi
alle nuvole siamo lanciafiamme diamo
fuoco alla gente e nono col pd o solo un
in francia c'è luogo più grande del
mondo esposta nel museo grazie di questa
news che senza non potevo vivere grazie
mille
come faccio ragazzi non accorti di
niente dpa sprangati in bocca un cazzo
mi servono colpi colpi di cose potreste
darmi dei forse questo colpi aveva della
colla munizioni wolfgan mica con la bold
gun faccio fuori la gente gol a bolt g
chemical in arma incredibile munizioni
devolve un colpo della revolver wow wow
davvero adesso sì che siano scorso
si possono contare
no comunicazioni sono ancora ci sente
cartucce per fucile c'è uno seduto tra
l'altro
disperati a dir poco c'è questo qua si
sta dondolando succedute ginocchia che
stimo tanto ti volevo dire che grazie
per ciò che fare grazie a te giulia
grazie a tema figurativo che faccio io
muoiono i giochi quindi figure porco de
maniera qua non ha visto però perché
orbo puoi tirarti per favore peraltro
aspetti prova a lanciare aspetta
ma perché si aspetta
cassa acustica che giace lottano
all'altro equipaggio la però equipaggia
la cassa equipaggia la ecco mai
sentito registrati vai e vai perfetto
devo passare minchia c'era un altro
quando l'avevo visto vorrei usare di più
in sintesi qualcosa che mi aveva visto
era orbo via via via via via via via via
deve usare il sintetizzatore vino via
via via via via via via via di lì a
cassetta cacchetta aia male male male
male male male non mi aveva visto cioè
come ha fatto non vedermi su entra molto
bene devo andare di qua non mi aveva
visto subito
ok apri portello voi la prima volta che
ne aprono così che figata
a brighi
e questo immagino dovevo andare di qua
giusto ma che sfiga
c'è gente ovunque kit medico non ho più
posso farne uno se sto bene vorrei farne
tanti in realtà prova per chi se ne
frega permesso alla fine gioco spero
bastino
meno male che ne ho un botto di
materiali per i kit medici 4 ai quattro
bastano di cui uno melo tiro adesso chi
come ryu chun colpi di niente avrei
evitato anche di sparare a quello di
prima sì però dovrete muovere di fate
qualcosa
per essere passo di quando mi vede
sull good
[Musica]
ti girare bravo così come arrivo devo
arrivare devo entrare qui in teoria
quindi va bene facendo terminare anche
se non mi serve a niente devono entrare
in quella stanza lì davanti a me stato
adattato a thatta ha sbloccato una cm
stai li guarda le fiamme bravo zio
complimenti tu sai che sei una vera
guardia
salviamo partita
ma tu le bollette le paghi felice io le
bollette no ma va a me arriva ad acqua
gratis e anche la esplicita del tutto
gratuita che sono tra i geo figura di
qua non c'è infatti dico ma c'è gente
anche qui ragazzino no colpi di nulla
quindi non ho niente per difendermi se
non un colpo di eccoti scusa un attimo
se non ti chiedo subito zio ma devo
vedere se mi danno proiettili o cose
perché siamo sono nella cacca questa
roba un pacco di carica ottimo e qua per
vedere quanti dei proiettili grande la
colla la colla vinilica quella di art
attack perfetto ciao
grazie a prezzo trova l'osservatorio
diceva e pro a pila ok non bastava
prendere
scusatemi il secondo raga che non
indolori aggiorna la pagina che mi serve
comitato difesa la pagina della live non
capisco perché c'è un problema di
youtube questo non sono la vera domanda
non è se ti arriva la bolletta ma di
quanto ti arriva di elettricità bastards
caso al mio computer che un po tira
considerando che viveva solo abbastanza
per il resto
sì la guardia di prima doveva studiare
come diventare una guardia con i
tutorial di aranzulla misa alzo un
pochettino il gioco che se perché cioè
gli assi e non so quanto mi manca alla
fine raga non lo so dovremmo esserci
perché eccoci qua
finalmente la sala comunicazioni
chiamiamo tutti chiamiamo oppure il
presidente
ok esattamente l'osservatore è
esattamente il punto dove volevo andare
quella volta non sono mai riuscito qua
c'è gente è figure stavolta uso la
bottega
gli sparo in faccia con la volte anzi
vorrei provare a fare posso provare una
volta a farlo se muoio chissenefrega
rifaccio so prevedere dai solo perché
voglio fare questa cosa l'ho mancato
c'è chi guarda ti un'acqua domani li
proviamo
ciao stavolta l'ho preso così perché mi
diverte fare questo modo ho preso quella
10 non prendere gol avanti ho preso con
la dietro ai a mazza zio che brutta mira
che c'hai un fai veramente schifo
cartucce finalmente c'è della roba che
posso tipo munizioni
ho preso scusami sei morta tu non volevo
prenderete però prova beh grazie lettore
munizioni levo almeno quello recuperato
un po di munizioni parlare evolve ho
preso quello dietro cartucce per fucile
da nolo te ne fai qualcosa tu io no
molto bene madonna che figata quello il
gigante rosso
bello stu pianeta
va bene come fai a sapere che il finale
perché mi ricordo è perché
ho chiesto nell'ultima laico qualche
percentuale e roero meno all'ottanta per
cento
due ore e mezza fa di gioco quindi se
non nel finale questo la matematica è
un'opinione e poi più o meno mi ricordo
che c'è si vede quando stai per arriva
alla fine di un gioco anzi in realtà
pensavo di esserci già arrivati invece
sta durando di più di quanto pensassi
salve buongiorno sono finalmente
riusciti a entrare qua dentro era meglio
non entrare
ecco l'unica cosa che mi dà fastidio
visto gioco che i corpi sono fermi cioè
non hanno la loro fisica peccato sarebbe
stato figo portare un corpo in giro
della serie come fanno nei giochi con i
giochi tipo anche in in fallout in
skyrim ti porti in giro i corpi troppo
divertente fine i numeri giusti terzo
vuol dire vuol dire a milano con i tasti
movimento pre video per confermarlo
mica solo dire no raga non sto capendo
poi si fa sta roba
me ne fai fare un altro che non sono
capace di fi a creare una di un altro
modo
no devo fare un futuro non ho capito
abbina i numeri giusti con tasti
movimento lo scemo io capisco demonio o
ero semplicemente questa barca non era
difficilissimo vai
devo controllare l'allineamento o
artefact giusto si sono bravissimo posso
andare nello spazio
posso lavorare alla nasa sono bravissimo
non pensavo di essere così bravo troppo
bravo solo se finisce youtube e vado
nello spazio c'è un diodo posto gioco
non ci vado prima prova e va bene grazie
di epic kevin e federico per graziano
tech insomma ciò che questo che la
stessa cosa
vabbè sta diventato e divertente per
lavorare alla nasa
pensavo fosse così semplice pensato di
studiare un sacco di tempo non serve a
niente basta fare così
basta usare i tasti di movimento
capitolari manualmente devo uscire esco
poi esco ok se riuscivano a mettere
coordinati se l'altro devo uscire
usciamo
come si esce siccome
ma ben capito non uscire devo andare
come tipo gli antennisti quando si
installavano la parabola di sky la
stessa cosa di telepiù
vabbè ma chi se lo ricorda delle più
solo io che sono secondo cura 23 anni
poi siamo stati il suo discorso e voi
che devo andare dello scico esco si esce
dove lui dov'è o se sì però il cac
cometa
dov'è la stanza dove si esce qua
cominciare
inserisci ma devo uscire nello spazio
come esco nello spazio c'è parlami
spacco la finestra esco così bon da una
porta che ne sa come che ne so che ne so
come si esce qua questa è l'uscita qua
dentro forse sono un velo dici che qua
io né calcio alla piantina della
dell'ama della nave in testa che
carillon e soia dove l'uscita ma scusami
ciao ale grazie mille per azione
i saluti e figurati cosa mi devo
aspettare ciao mattia tanto per poi tra
l'altro mi saluti sono mattia un nome
alessandro vabbè vabbè grazie minuti mi
ha aperto questa porta e non sapevo che
era questa la porta ma mi salvare va
external array sì sì sì sì sì
stavamo
molto bene prendiamo alla tuta calvin
klein
in realtà c'è la piantina della nave si
ma non mi indicava a questo punto questo
punto preciso capito cioè mi indicava
fuori ma se io sapessi come uscire a
passo di cambiarmi va bene quindi
volendo posso tornare anche su così non
batteria scarica
vuoi usare l'ascensore solo una volta
cui si scarica la batteria
ok non ascensore proprio nuova
generazione va bene c'è va bene a
minchia sono proprio vabbè fa caldo qui
ma stai zitto che sono io fuori quindi
se vuoi venire a fare il lavoro lo fai
tutto pagato 1 cat
poi c'è un pezzo che vola che è entrato
nella nave va bene le figata
è questa parte veramente [ __ ] e non mi
ricordo come finisce alien ma zero
l'altro pezzo tutti dentro
mica quanto lento cammino più veloce mia
nonna
poi tra l'altro scusate io che io sta
cosa non l'ho mai capita ma work a bach
questo voglio vedere come gli passa
attraverso hanno lì è passato di fianco
beh devo dire io non non ho mai capito
come faccia la vittima come faccio
adesso a rimanere attaccato qua scusami
nello spazio non boli cevoli non c'è la
gravità quindi come fai a rimanere
perché sto camminando perché la tuta è
calamitata il terreno c'è il terreno al
pavimento
questa cosa non la capisco qualcuno che
lavora la nasa che sta seguendo la live
uno dei tanti che lavorano la nasa che
si stanno seguendo la live mi spiegano
cosa come faccio a rimanere appiccicato
sei sono uno spazio
nel terminale si quale dove spesso non
dove è quello il termine ok alla tuta
pesante non c'entra un cazzo pesante
volo ua non c'è la gravità i piedi
magnetici è quello che pensavo io ci
sono i pesi nella tutta non c'entra
niente
cioè almeno se la fisica la so che non
la so perché di per carità quindi potrei
fare una gara incredibile il peso non
c'entra un cazzo c'entra niente il bello
sarà ora è tutta magnetica
ma poi determinano un bagno acqua
capisci picchu in torinese moriremo
scemo perché è un videogioco
immagino che ci siano le scarpe
magnetiche
sì però non mi sta facendo noi via
rilascio del ghiaccio pavia
a si sta avviando grazie a dio almeno
vedo vedevo niente
poi tra l'altro sta parte è
completamente fuori nello spazio super
carino emergenza o inutilizzabile per
adesso no adesso no
bello modo mito soloni meccanico
ci sono dei magneti sottoli
gli stivali raga non sapete la secondo
me non sapete la fisica dice non è che
più pesa un oggetto e soggetto pesa
rimane attaccato a terra non c'entra
niente quello allora scusami futuro che
ieri uno che pesa 100 kg i know how può
andare trotterellare nello spazio perché
ho solo la voce in testa e io che non ne
peso cento no
che c'entra quel calamità o se non lo so
ci tra la serie al peso c'è un centro un
cazzo il peso nello spazio anche nelle
fante invola galleggiano celli soffre
della gravità nello spazio che non c'è
quindi non c'entrasse che cazzo devo
andare qua a sorry sorry e uscire non
capivo si capisce ogni volta sono
e soprattutto e soprattutto nei film
dove non c'è la gravità tipo gravity
inter stella non sono tutti i film dove
sono nello spazio che la gente
volteggiano nella navicella no e fanno a
girare quelle scene non vanno
assolutamente nello spazio ma come le
girano con le scene di questa cosa mi
sapete rispondere questa una domanda
molto più importante di quello che vi ho
fatto bene quella che non l'ho mai
capita come come fanno a simulare la
gravità zero ci sono stanze che simulano
la gravità zero nel mondo
penso lo sbaglio non lo so lo so io so
quello che sto facendo
porco demonio non ci toccano aspetti
perché mancino con altro tedesco
aspettate un attimo arrivo with a secco
[Musica]
oggi oggi ho un ospite speciale che vi
presento adesso posso dire una
parolaccia no mica un po addosso
ciao mipiace ciao ragazzi
hai visto sin live sentieri ingrata mia
armi ha citofonato quest'uomo ciao ciao
ciao e per quello che non mi risponde
l'emorragia e novi chiamato ci stava
registrando va beh se non faccio due ore
e mezzo non importa però moda min
io intanto faccio quello che vuoi non so
dove guardare la vedevi guardare con un
ciao
ecco si stanno salutando mi va bene ti
piace vista va bene e scusatemi
ininterrotto sono centrato no cosa può
fare e giusto usa usa tasti di movimento
per selezionare le coordinate e premi e
per cosa
premi e per che cosa
cosa che devo fare conversione
coordinate 35 premi e per che cosa devo
premere quali sono le coordinate della
torrents sono 35 a 35 dove mettere premi
e per per per per qualcosa premia 35
giusto così molto bene questi movimento
75 e figata e ci fa quando cambi la
radio la frequenza
premi e ha perso cazzo 75
ho cambiato manualmente come gli
antennisti come i tennisti
ma
usano gli effetti speciali per fare i
film grazie no veramente non grazie
perché ti giuro se la persona che mi ha
dato una risposta veramente accurata non
so proprio come ringraziarti capito che
usano gli effetti speciali ma come fanno
a simulare la gravità è quello il fatto
e devo andare e non si dicono le
parolacce un organismo alieno city
dobbiamo aspettare qualsiasi va a tutte
le mie live per capire va bene
cerca di far attraccare la torre
sì ma mi dici dove devo andare a lato
della stazione quindi in che punto
quando torna dentro asi porco demonio
fanno le scene in acqua no perché
parlano anche ci sono i simulatori
antigravità è vero loro usano organi
script braga lo so che fanno gli effetti
degli effetti speciali ma capiti che
capite che è veramente una cosa
incredibile simulare l'antigravità in
acqua
li attaccano con dei cavi e pero i
movimenti degli arti sarebbero troppo
innaturali credo con dei cavi
io io nella mia testa ho sempre pensato
che ci fossero delle camere fatte
propria green screen tutte dove
all'interno si simula la gravità zero
anche se non so se si può in realtà non
so neanche se si può fare strada
immagino io penso che sia così perché
non trovo mo non capisco se non è così
non capisco come si fa come facciano a
registrare certe scene non lo capisco
e proprio una cosa che non riesco a
capire
quindi non so se ci sono sostanze anti
gravità o se si attaccano a dei cavi per
i cavi non dovrebbero simulati propri
movimenti precisi dell'anti gravità che
sveglia e se ti tirano da un cavo cioè
non so come dire però ci sono dei
macchinari che tolgono la gravità borno
se ronaldo si allena in una stanza
gravità doppia tipo crocs aleph ragazzi
usano l'effetto pac man e l'effetto pac
man
la risposta sta nel terapia business la
gravità di un pianeta è data dal nucleo
pianeta e piatto quindi non esiste il
nucleo quindi ci stiamo mettendo vicenda
anche quei ventilatori si vedrebbe i
capelli che svolazzano quindi non sono
anche per quello non lo so ora ganso non
esistono le camere antigravità infatti
allora il mio una mia fantasia
non lo so allora alcuni dicono che
esistono le distanze gravità alcuni
dicono non lo so se esistono nostre
stanze ampie gravidanza io ho sempre
pensato fosse così perché se no non me
lo spiego
magari esistono non lo so io se esistono
voglio provarne una tutta la vita voglio
provarne una assolutamente
esistono perché vegeta sia allenato lì
ho capito che cosa che succede si è
chiuso il tappo quindi porco demonio
four se se io raggiungo il punto di
evacuazione quando auto nella ricardo
grazie riccardo per questa incredibile
compagnia che mi fai ott
molto bene vediamo se riesco a passarli
vicino senza farli incazzare in qualche
modo magari se c'è la corrente posso
passare sotto i condotti tipo lì sotto
se si gira sono cazzi forse se posso
passare qua sotto
posso passare qua sotto
ora che abbiamo tirato fuori un
dibattito allucinante tra esistono le
stanze anteriorità e non esistano le
stanze antigravità praga non sapremo mai
come sono fatti chi nello spazio mai c'è
un dibattito abnorme nei con me esistono
non possa esistere non possono esistere
tutto questo aliena sopra la mia testa
ed è sempre molto sexy
ma dov'è
ma dove mai sceso no sono riuscito a
nero girarlo ecco visto non mi ha visto
non mi ha visto forse mi ha visto non mi
ha visto non mi ha visto non mi ha visto
incredibile non me orbo avessi quello lo
sapevo già neanche sordo
ciao andrea c'è un miriana ciao a
leonardo lo ricordo porterebbe stretti
grazie salvatorica santonio grazioli per
grazie filippo grazie al e federico la
nazione
minchia un attimo grazie mickey lampo 89
esiste esistono solo in australia ci
sono i tesori che si allenano insieme
quei giganti sono brownies era
esattamente il tipo di risposta che
stava aspettando
esatto io sono questo ragazzo qua io sto
con mickey lampo esistono le stanze
antigravitazionali sono in australia noi
ci sono il primo zauri con i giganti
bravo ma post oliver portale farfalla
non lo so perché l'ho già giocato in
anteprima tra l'altro molto che minchia
mi sono scagliato addosso che in solo
marco l'ho già giocato da solo però da
solo dopo un po mi ero rotto le balle
magari con degli amici e divertente non
lo so se lo porto prima o poi non so
addio santissimo riccardo va beh
non ci credo è scemo e scemo e scemo
scivolo dirò sempre quello scemo
importante che sia scemo riccardo è
morto ma chi se ne frega perché tanto
era la persona inutile favi mio babbo
lavora nella nasa
ma si sa che il mio video lavorava
hollywood non so se è vero che hai detto
o no ieri al papa chiama un attimo fi
babbo scusami ma le stanze
antigravitazionali esistano che glielo
chiedi un secondo per favore perché se
non c'è un dibattito in corso capito
potresti interno fine a questo dibattito
che cosa minchia resto rumore non c'è
dove era soprattutto poi riccardo dove
ai software
da dove dove dove non l'ho mai capito da
dove venissero ma da dove veniva venisse
c'è gente che mi saluta fuori dalla
porta
cav h questa roba qua da quand'è che
esiste non ho mai provato la molotov su
aliena quindi proviamo
ciao chi è che maschili scusami ciao
jordan e ciò filippo ciao gigi ciao
isaia viene spesso ti prego saluta
saluta il pubblico
sto finendo al in isole jean miche ma
mai avuto visitando agenti vita durante
una live fini scariolo
ok e ciao filippo ciao isaia ciao
miliano
ci sono delle camere di caduta libera ma
non vedo come possano aiutare le camere
di caduta libera gli aerei stimolano la
gravità zero ho capito io sto parlando
in una stanza dove ti puoi muovere
parlare quindi non è neanche sott'acqua
io non sto capendo
io non avrò mai una risposta vera in
quella questa domanda sarebbe troppo
bello sia la linea stilistica gli altri
dalla discesa brina fuori dalla porta e
ragazzi casa mia mi frega quanta gente
c'è se corro se la rascio lahrach
tarascio laraia che male tua madre che è
male mi hai fatto agli a porco de mori
va fatto malissimo la lascio cosa perché
domandare di andare a destra pensa testa
questa strana porco schifo che male mi
ha fatto mi ha fatto malissimo via via
via ho lasciata hanno fatto bene
trump arriva anche cristiano ronaldo
mica veramente ciò lancio parti in casa
mentre baciava e si può simulare
l'antigravità grazie alla è quello lo
sapevo però quello lo sapevo il problema
è che non mi piace puoi girare un film
su un aereo
basta stiamo tirando fa un discorso
troppo lungo per un assemblata c'è
stronzata
o c'è un tizio cerca di far attaccare la
torre c'è un tizio quindi io sparo mi fa
ridere che la gente non fa attenzione a
dargli non solo io faccio attenzione ad
aliano c aliens in giro non lo so
sicilia e quindi se sparo gli va addosso
però non posso nascondermi quindi muoio
anche io quindi non sbarcano non
spariamo cerca di far attaccare la
torres però la navetta dove arriva
mi ha visto non è visto è scemo scemo da
qui comincia
porca vacca ricordo l'ultima volta che
ho torto
quindi è molto stanco non lo vede
con un propulsore
varie probabilmente mi ha sentito lo
segue
io volevo fare io ho io ho sono salvo io
gli ho dato le botte perché volevo
proprio fare silenzio ci voleva
ucciderlo silenziosamente no perché non
volevo calin arrivarsi niente
l'idea iniziale andata [ __ ] quindi
ok l'ho fatto piano apposta io parte che
non vuole anche andare di qua dal tuo
presa infatti però devo muovermi perché
non ha più colpi non ha più colpi molto
bene
quindi devo venire di qua sul serio la
cosa devo fare qua c'è la porta lì che
mi niuna ho salvato il sì questa porta
le pristina della corrente figura
come ripristino la corrente che ci sono
dei punti sto gioco che proprio non
capisco ogni volta che c'è un tastino
magari che devi schiacciare piccolo così
per quello porca vacca questa porta qua
si aprirà mai perché codice d'accesso
figurati denunciava niente da figure se
c'è qualcosa d'altro
ah ecco la torcia joniche web
devo usare il medico porca vacca stavo
morendo non ho mica visto e fatto
malissimo o che è successo ma aiuta e mi
piace né crociato alien vi si sta
aggiornando ali e nel mentre che stava
già la live
ma no ma cacciato ma porca vacca me
crociato alien li mortacci sua ma dai è
crashato aveva meno stato della porta
intanto salvato l'itis vermiglia pensa
se sarà una parte che non salvo da una
vita e mezza mamma mia che ansia
porca vacca meno male che ho salvato
minchia meno male cosa mammamia pensa se
era una live ma è cresciuto alien ma
così poi ma per cosa per cosa mia che mi
è mia crociata burul capito
wow sono veramente contento per
cresciuto allison e cioè sorry sorry e
bo bo coser anno aveva salvato quindi
chi se ne frega
come qualche meglio
però c'è ancora tit che gira quindi
aspettiamo che finisca di girare
speriamo non mi spari nella schiena e
siamo a posto
sta venendo di qua ma speriamo che non
mi veda se mi vede sono morti però va
bene o non tralasciare di nuovo visto
sollecito anche risparmiare un botto di
colpi tre infarti un cane 1851 1871 1851
e ma come doveri avvio la 1851 si parla
dove metto sto codice ho avuto alla
porta il codice di accesso della porta
ero che ho capito lo ritrovi libici
dimmi che non è il tipo davanti a me
io lo sapevo tanto io lo sapevo io lo
sapevo io lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
lo stato io lo sapevo già c'è neanche
bisogno di spiegarlo sapevo
allora gesù lo sapevo lo sapevo se c'è
una possibilità ma non c'era il codice
qua scusa aspettami stop era è la
cornice della regista porta qua che
pirla 1851 sì sì sì me lo ricordo grazie
che non ri scrivete in chat perché sono
caduti dove ricaricare potresti andar
via
grazie
ogni tanto sono sporto nella videocamera
un buono
ok ho riavviato la quindi il posto
tornando indietro
va bene no
quando gli ho sparato raga e non ho più
colpiti c'è ne ho ma non bastano per
mandarlo via
quindi o move in ci muoviamo ok ho
finito i colpi questo era l'ultimo
proiettile di lanciafiamme che ciò non
c'erano più perfetto mi servirebbe se ha
rivali e non so come mandarlo via rega
non so come mandare via lì se non con la
molotov accedere al terminale italiani
perfetto sono messo sotto la schiena non
c'è
non ho più colpi non ho più col pd per
il mio lanciafiamme perfetto si siano
sostenendo ma non accettiamo che fa
rumore ma stato non va neanche quindi
[Musica]
andato
vai via che palle
ce ne sono chiamarla navetta
[Musica]
ma
sono stato fermo immobile il più
possibile in b il più possibile porco
schifo
[Musica]
adesso perché non c'è più cioè nei
condotti che fanno male perché sono non
sono era infatti vi questo non c'aveva
niente
che palle io mi metto questo qua dietro
perfetto
stiamo qua
ok
no no no no no no no no no
ap ma [ __ ] va dai che palle che
palle
dai che palle due ore e mezza poi
minchia che palle o mamma mia che palle
allucinante lega due
ma da ieri è vero anche dentro poi la
porta per chiudersi 6 ore ci metteva
proviamo poi ci mette 1 ora da riverso
schifo
qua cioè tu un'ora ad arrivare quando
file
ci godo si gode lo dicevo io
all'elementari dico vi ricordo ero
piccolissimo otto amici probabilmente
anche due però è né riportato alla mente
giovinezza
mostro qua fermo
ma dov'è
porca vacca che cagà grazie francesco
grazie mille che sei anche oggi guarda
thank you so much mi chiami sono kakà i
passi di aline sembrano politi mia mamma
super incazzato e vero conferma
ma c'è un alien al secondo subito col
qua che palle ma preferiamo quest'anno
la navetta di fianco non è la navetta lì
ci sono chi fianco a prima con schifo
strega devo salvare no no no no no
minchia che previdente che sono stato
non venire qua non venire qua non venire
qua non venire qua non venire qua non
venire qua non venire non venire
mammamia rega
mamma mia
effetto opaco ma no è successo
l'effetto opaco ma nel senso che sono
tornato d'oro prima aiuto e con questa è
una delle mie fobie degli ascensori ho
sempre paura che succeda questa cosa so
perché salva
lo demonio qualsiasi cosa faccia esplode
tutto
trova uno strato salve porca vacca
vabbè tanto tanti colpi venga venga ma
non è andato giù come possibile e fare
come ha fatto a resistere poi questi
cammino non è d'accordo
dai dai dai
l'amica verrà dove sono io questo c'è un
casinò durante c'è un casino di tutta la
nave dei vini al proprio a me
vai a destra qualsiasi cosa vuoi fare la
tua vita devi muoverti ragazze non mi
muovo io mi ammazza lui se non mi muove
la mazzali nuovo saline il condotto ti
prego che culo scapito sorella
praga devo sparare a quel tizio
dove vado devo passati qua sai che non
sono vere guarda che se mi fai ammazzare
ti ammazzo
minchia che botta l'ho ucciso con la
clava martellino non è nemmeno mai
successo
ne ha preso lo stesso l'aveva ucciso col
martelletto incredibile e non sparno
dello sparare come faceva ucciderlo come
lo ammazzavo spiegami a 1 da una parte
un'ora all'altra macello sarà comunque
dovrei avere dei colpi del lanciafiamme
per mandare via jan che non ho più
quindi non faccia solo ed esclusivamente
con la forza delle ninja con questa
parte i ragazzi non ho mica capito dove
l'ondata che lo dico ha detto rocco mi
fa andare dietro e la domanda è la
molotov serve contro ali non ve lo
chiedo adesso che finito il gioco
praticamente non c'era niente nel
condotto venuti e sto condotto
fantastico con razzo poi distrarlo ok
allora facciamo così cassa acustica è
però il problema
facciamo parlare del caso gusto il
problema è che c'è il robot pure quindi
io faccio fuori e robot e all in e me lo
gestisco dopo la cassa acustica e per
gli strali questo e per ilo cosa
facciamo
ma dov'è anni dietro era o lo spacco sto
tipo adesso o non lo spacco però devo
muovermi questa parte è difficilissima
ma dovevo andare scusatemi mi dite
milite nel mentre che cerco di
sopravvivere asti 2 deficienti dove devo
andare
grazie lattina che pola dove devo andare
me lo dite per cortesia mentre cerco di
farlo
accorciano i tempi c'è un terminale di
nostri cieli terminali ok ce n'è uno li
lo vedo lì
tesserà d'accesso chi è che c'ha la
tesserato accesso scusami ma quello è
tornato indietro
bene bene bene bene ma adatta benissimo
stavolta spero di non morire perché non
tornerò mai chiesta posizione devo
alzare il muletto colo alzo
col terminale alzo il muletto con l'alza
il muletto
evacuare la stazione non è
un'esercitazione
ricerca sensori dietro alza il muletto
scusate ma un miscela ma dai che palle
poi mi avete rotto il cazzo due ali nel
mi avete rotto lo dico allora ma porco
demonio se ti spara in faccia muorinho
amori cristo ma dai non muore
guarda guarda sei colpi in faccia o
valori cioè tifare cosa ho appena fatto
che non è servito perché adesso michele
ha bisogno gli ho dato una cravatta a
dahlia tv o è servito invece dai dai dai
dai dai dai veloce
cosa devo fare non c'era l'androide la
tessera ci ho provato
dammi in codice qualcosa non so cosa
razzo non c'era l'android la tessera li
mortacci vostri cazzo me dite pezzi di
metallo nessuno c'è niente dai trovare
velocissimo qualcosa sono morto 1984
1984 il codice vengo al mondo d'estate
preparava dio mi parla nel sonno minchia
salmo 1984 il codice dello sportello va
bene ti pare
se entrare in sono morto non ho più
lanciafiamme l'ho usato per questo
questo non ho avuto quattro 1984 giuro è
questo il codice hays c'è anche cos'è
lanciafiamme prendi tutto
caricare calcia piano credibile non solo
farmi ok la tessera d'accesso serve a a
quel coso lì ok ok in chi sa che è
difficile sta parte semole tazio muletto
bravo nicchia un ora poi ci passi
tranquillamente 1984 è questa la
difficile di condimenti carmen a rega
salmo il codice russell crowe è sì kit
medico
minchia il medico di razzi avermelo
detto sono morto praticamente porco
schifo che è difficile stava fatevi
salvare per forlì farò mai più
non riuscirò mai più a rifarla datemi un
punto di salvataggio vi prego non
salverà mai più impossibile gallino qua
datemi un punto in cui salvare perché
non muoio preghiamo in gesù cristo non
mi prende nessuno se non muoio muoio ve
lo giuro muoio se non mi fate salvare
adesso muoio
che razza essa è un alien
c'è ti pare
devo salvare l'uomo mi cresce al gioco
non ce la farò mai più e tornare qua in
questo punto e ve lo dico in questo
punto non tornò più mai più
se non vinco adesso non vinco più ma è
mai più nella mia vita mai proprio su
stato fatto niente
un salvataggio lì dentro non si apre la
porta
aprite lo vedo el al salvataggio
apritevi ecco dai minchia
funzioni per il tono essere così serve
il tonfo raga vi prego fatemi aprite
salvate la partita se non se non ce la
farò mai più a rifare questo pezzo mai
più
dai dai dai dai
sì sì sì sì di qua il fornitore minchia
dai schifo o di madonna non ci avrei mai
più rifatto a fare quel punto mai più
veloce ma ad uscire di là dal condotto
i ragazzi da questo stanno facendo da un
orario soldato
a causare questo cielo la tessera ciao
cielo non ce l'ho
non ho la tessera vendola aprendo forse
c'è una tessera l'ho trovata l'ho
trovata c'è anche un coso per terra e
morto
penso che sia morto però in questo
momento forse ho attirato un po la
tensione di alien veloce quindi veloce
veloce e velocemente in chiaro all 80
per cento la gente mi aveva detto porca
vacca in può entrare può entrare con
trapani
minchia dove che devo andare dove devo
andare
arrivano a fermi con arrivo lì come armi
voli ma come arrivo lì a rivoli come a
rivoli
procedi all'evacuazione è ma dov'è il
tuo fa il giro
aliena eccolo perfetto no
mica son riuscito a sfuggire molto bravo
senza neanche usare lanciafiamme devo
andare al all'evacuazione ma non ho
capito esattamente dove penso sia qua no
no ho sbagliato
nel mese di maggio ore
potevo salvare la partita perché non lo
salva da è andato
quest'anno però c'è un altro cosa per
salvare
ok
ma doveva attivare aspetta fatemi
lasciare un attimo perché voglio vedere
una cosa lascia un attimo
scusatemi se lascio lo vedrà una cosa
assolutamente
a parte che non mi sta cagando lo stesso
blog dovremo attivarlo questo no
generatore in funzione non dovevo
attivarlo infatti che mi avete eletto
attiva lo non devo attivarlo non doveva
attivare niente continuato solo questo
quindi ok niente questo non lo sa per
basta volevo solo vedere se doveva
attivare sta roba qua quindi corriamo se
mi vede bene se no non ti sei stato
salvato se me la sono fatta tutta di
corsa non mi ha pagato vabbè se noi
perché si è spostato di qua quindi
adesso li caricano bene
e giusto dovuta un'eco indietro e giusto
dove minchia devo andare lega di qua no
il quale meno croce un tipo morto
vorrei capire come me ne vado
quando lo stabilizzatore ordinaria
abbandonare la nazione sì grazie
grazie del consiglio davvero
ah è vero il rilevatore da un seguire
che pirla me lo dimentico sempre questo
mi dice dove devo andare allora era
giusto era di qua devo seguire il
rilevatore scusatemi mi dimentico sempre
allora giusto no scusate ma era giusto
era giusto nel giusto era giusto di qua
ecco lo hai visto
e bastato non gli è bastato gli è
bastato minchia erano 75 colpi di
lanciafiamme sono gli bastavano so io
meno male che mi avete nemmeno mai mete
non mi ricordavo il rilevatore di cosa
c'è adesso non ho neanche più colpite
lanciafiamme di avvio
ecco adesso adesso devo riavviare il
generatore porco demonio non si può
rifare questa parte
la demonio a vedere ricarico dovevo
attivare il gene meno male perché
[Musica]
ero qua vicino quindi perfetto mi
dimentico sempre che si proseguire
questo aveda non importa meno ci colpì
lanciafiamme
24 gol imbarazzante
e mo che nessuno dove ok
è che palle
che culo meno male almeno quello però
non torno indietro a gesù
adesso devo andare a tirare generatore
mai
perché sa bene da dove territorio perché
deve fare controlli perché è piccolo e
adesso devo fare vaccino poi devo rifare
il vaccino ma dove devo andare io devi
andare tu è figura che penso così
scusatemi un muretto ciao francesco di
terapisti hanno ragione lo so ciao
laricio mickey chokri bat privato
arouca ciao ciao giulia ciao ale e luchi
se scori tutta l'acqua vedi dove devi
andare sia in basso a destra lo so però
non vedi che non c'è era qua
l'ho anche io avevo visto solo che non
c'è il ceco si dice non ti fa vedere la
strada che devi fare per arrivare fino
alla
pizza o sushi dipende dal giorno
dipende dal giorno schizza
tendenzialmente ho riavviato generatore
ha fatto un casino bojan
aridaje questo punto qua
seguiamo rilevato
[Musica]
che palle
quello che mi tocca e se ne va
bellissimo perchè gli ho dato scarica di
fiamme e quindi non le sopporta e allora
mi toccassero randomicamente parlano c'è
lui mi tocca e se ne va
dai dov'è il mondo è una nota
mica funzionato ma vero che il saluto
alla mamma no la mamma mamma sai tv io
voglio salutare giacomo il mio vicino
super mega bravissimo a far le robe
perché se live al grande ha già comunque
giacomino ma che cacchio fatto dentro è
fra scioglie lo so infatti io sto
resistendo loro non lo sanno guai anche
a noi sta resistendo tantissimo
benissimo e io tra
minchia funzionato la molotov
corri tocco
[Musica]
sofia
da donna io torno indietro a prescindere
poi ricordo arriva rigori corica ripari
non ho più niente per niente non ho più
niente non ho più niente proposto
salvare ma dovevo andare di qua non
vorrei salvare la partita ma vabbè
salviamo infatti non doveva andare di
qua di mortacci the pooh sorella però io
non vedo quando corro non vedo da dove
doveva andare quadro tornata di qua
torna indietro è quindi sono complicato
la vita
legadue così insieme non le posso fa o
mi salvo
occorre adesso provo a non correre
[Musica]
non ci passi non ci passa quindi alla
fine era di nuovo di qua un porco
demonio era la porta di prima sì ci
arrivò secondo
la mia vita una merda è una merda sapevo
dove dovevo andare e non ci sono sapevo
dove dovevo andare e non ci sono andato
io sapevo esattamente dove dovevo andare
e non ci sono andato
e cazzo di cose servono per fare una
molotov
se una ne ho potuto fare una o una sola
vabbè
era dalla stanza di fianco invece sono
ho dovuto correre fino qua per sbaglio
c'è per sbaglio perché non fate che non
ha vita cioè zero di vita vabbè non mi
curo neanche perché tanto muoio a
prescindere o no o mi curo sicuro e
dovrebbe mancare poco la faccia in
teoria che palle o come non la pirata ma
cristo gesù cristo
al banco cammina poi mi devo rifare il
molo di nuovo di molti metto sei ore per
gesù
[Musica]
non lo stabilizzatore ordinario
abbandonare la campione ama curare la
frazione si infatti non lo sto tenendo
la molotov in mano perché fa bordello
grazie che ribatte al solito thank you
bacino
faccia bairati
puoi andare via
evacuare la stazione con determinazione
puoi salire salire
dopo l'evacuazione e citano rientrare
nella stagione a meno che non sia stato
ordinato dal coordinatore di emergenza
dai che palle
no a gesù niente 6 ore 6 ore
ma perfetto è uscito ieri va bene è
diventato metalli a webber
devo andare là a destra l'ictus
cos'è la mia arma l'impegno quando le
armi le lascio in giro non ho capito che
sono stato cioè io veramente dunque fa
più caldo qua dentro che sevastopol
dentro la mia stanza dico era qua che
doveva andare qua a destra era lì da sei
ore che significa tonfa milano è uno che
canta porca vacca che botta io da
minchia
e stato bellissimo vai vai la rai ci sei
è stato bellissimo porco schifo che
botta mica può rinfaccia bug assurdo
figo
ho finito le molotov non è proprio una
bella news ma
è [ __ ]
minchia magari non so non so non so non
so non so più di coopi di così io non
potevo fare questa volta più di minchia
iotti lato una gara una molotov in bocca
o corso quando sono uscito la seconda
più di così non potevo fare questo e il
mio massimo cioè non mi si può chiedere
di più in quella parte lì l'ho fatta la
perfezione non so se è se esce di fisso
sempre esce sempre lì a quanto pare no
molto bene
minchia che volta gli ho dato prima
stato assurdo mai
1984 ma linee cretino che non lo vedono
aline ceco ha a volte ceco a volte veda
volte c'è cerca di fare attraccare la
torrents finirà mai
l'incontro noti qua
però non ci sia lì devo imparare a
seguirlo strafare comunque perché anche
soffitto il gioco ormai perché ti dice
esattamente dove devi andare
avrei risparmiato tanto di quel tempo
l'uso la tubo bomba va bene ma turbo ma
non è quella di le for dead cazzo ci fai
qua dietro non dalla vai yeah
vi chiama statura ma sai che non pensavo
così tanto dura veramente un botto penso
sia finito
scappa la sepa da sevastopol sebastopol
la pipe bomb esplode subito la pippa
bomba contro l'azienda
di menardi in testa in testa ma avvia la
procedura di attracco e no indietro
eccolo lì
ok ti devo andare
dice domanda di qua
qua adobe ripristinato ma dovete lo
scemo
guardi qua no
minchia ma devo ripristinare la corrente
prima come faccio
vanno lì ok ok all animale
l'odio ma [ __ ]
per questo e pa
l'altro
ma l'altro qua è spento
praga è spento non sono scemo ripristino
della corrente va bene se capissi cavi
se quei cavi
segui cardi campione della lunga sta
guarendo seguì capire la ripristino
spento k h
eccolo
mi piace ansia sul serio
[Musica]
ritirati io sto con ciccio sia adesso lo
faccio per intanto grazie dei soldi
oddio
ecco gli colla va bene
[Musica]
babele quella terminale si c'è uno sto
facendo tutto fermo
la fece perché se mi beccavo adesso me
ne andavo
attiva cancellate la co sang soo
attraccate che palle
minchia ricaccio una molotov una una
40 sì mi ricordo
[Musica]
qui è tutto infuocato legato nella cacca
piena
ma
come tu che cazzo dici
come più
che mi dice vedo torna indietro minchia
sta esplodendo tutto dove minchia devo
andare ma come giu laggiù dove qui si
scemo
poco demonio può andare di qua di sotto
che non è vero come wire 8 funziona come
ci ha voglia
non è vero guarda che posso fare
non è vero che quando il mio no no no no
non adesso non adesso
porco schifo in terra dai che palle
perché adesso cristo 1 ora che ne usciva
sì sì
mi sarà il finale porco schifo
no di nuovo no no no ma di nuovo ma no
di mono l'ho già fatto l'ho già fatto
gli organici questo credo ve lo giuro su
dio ve lo giuro su dio non ci credo ma
perché cazzo ma basta io mi ha commosso
tutto il c'è questo quadro se rimani
così accovacciato funziona se no no ma
cristo dai ma poi glielo lanciato poi
gliel'ho pure la tutto il tutto insieme
tutti insieme e l'ho lanciata non glie
l'ha lanciata occorso un metro e mi ha
preso tutto in tutti c'è un bordello
sulla nave vicente solo me incredibile
ciao amico
thank you non ho sentito prima scusami
per avevo concitato grazie mille
ciao case
sono quasi le 18 di un accordo non sono
ancora le 18 set
sicché caldo meno tre
vedi l'ora
eh si non capivo prossimo
porca vacca
non c'è la pasta al dente e lo so ci
vuole duro allenamento in live per
riuscire mica come sta reggendo madonna
fa veramente calzolaio di giurare
incredibile sono uscito a vedere
vai dove cazzo ma come bloccato hanno
avviato il corso
minchia sta sudando giuro
no sto facendo tutto accovacciate rai
allora che dovrebbe finire tutto alle 18
sono le 17 59 perché lei 18 loro muoiono
dentro non possa altre 35 minuti rifiuti
perché devo recare la mia vita è così
ragazzo è un'ansia dietro l'altro
[Musica]
se vi rendete conto vi rendete conto
dove sono morto
[Musica]
incredibile incredibile
io devo camminare ditemi voi se io devo
camminare così ditemelo
io devo camminare così perché se mi alzo
muoio
solo il 18 lo so parti spero ma finisce
ad e quanto omicidio c'è ancora un po e
allora non posso finirlo oggi il live
perché non posso devo concludere adesso
non devo divertirmi devo andare a
registrare altri video
mancano nè di temi solo adesso finisce o
no
[Musica]
sbagliato una giusta prova usare la tubo
bomba rega se non funziona vi ammazzo
vabbè
sto lasciando è
raga tanto comunque non ce l'avrei fatta
lo stesso a finirlo
non ce l'ho fatto io è vero bo
incredibile pensavo
pensavo che in questa live penso io
pensavo che questa live durasse
questi c'è tipo mezz'ora e poi per i
restanti due ore io pensavo di dover
fare altro e invece non è andata così
c'è nel senso che pensavo pensavo fosse
finito al inceppa finito invece no
dite che manca ancora un'altra mezz'ora
quindi non posso e devo finire alle 18
dove non devo registrare non posso farlo
quindi la prossima io l'unica cosa che
odio e fare una live tipo dove finisco
tipo nella prossima rai definisco ali
dall'inizio e poi faccio due ore
un'altra cosa
quindi è orribile c'è perché uno che
vuole vedersi tutto alien vede poi che
inizia un altro video è brutto però non
posso più fare non posso che aspettare
devo devo andare via adesso non è il
finale raga non è in finale di alien
quanto cazzo dura sto gioco 4 al 5 live
da due ore e mezza non finisce mai e
devo cambiare la copertina aveva detto
quella parte 5 non finale cazzo assurdo
e quindi la possibilità faccio la parte
6 10 minuti a iemmello finito e poi un
altro gioco che cosa faccio sempre un
problema delle live
in realtà però non possiamo fare
nient'altro io purtroppo ragazzi ora
devo andare non posso stare di più
perché devo andare a registrare altri
video
fare lo youtube era facile e quindi devo
devo staccare per andare a registrare
altre cose poi niente quindi aspetto ego
finale dal titolo lascio parte 5 cambia
miniatura mettiamo parte 5 non aveva e
continua nella prossima vi scusatemi
larga non posso finirlo oggi ci avrei
voluto ma non posso quindi niente ci
vediamo giovedì vi ringrazio
grazie df ming la donazione mi stai
stancheranno grazie ci vediamo la
prossima volta
faremo una live di dieci minuti dura
molto più di mezz'ora come
non pensano vabbè dai provini sia
piaciuto ragazzi ci vediamo giovedì sera
e consensi
come ti piace quindi sa come tenere se
siete decidiamo allora prossima lei da
ragazzi